phénomènes rares à Montréal les
températures dépassent les normales
saisonnières depuis deux semaines en
plein après-midi de novembre le mercure
grimpe même à plus de 20 degrés Celsius
la ville reprend ses airs de printemps
ce magnifique on profite on se balade on
déjeune enfin voilà c'est génial
j'en profite beaucoup c'est vraiment
très beau c'est super pour travailler
sur ce vignoble le temps chaud est à
l'inverse source de stress
clairement les premiers bourgeons sont
stimulés
de vigne à Saint-Bruno de Montarville si
la température dépasse encore les 10
degrés dans les deux prochains jours il
va perdre sa récolte de l'an prochain
avec cette chaleur la sève monte et fait
sortir activement les premiers bourgeons
du printemps là actuellement si par
exemple on perd c'est pas moi une
dizaine de bourgeons par plan la récolte
va être diminuée de moitié
l'année prochaine ça c'est sûr donc un
impact direct au niveau des revenus de
l'entreprise depuis deux jours il a
cessé de tailler les vignes pour ne pas
stimuler davantage les bourgeons
résultat il prend du retard pour la
préparation de son vignoble pour l'hiver
une première en 17 ans
l'industrie des arbres de Noël tourne
aussi au ralenti la coupe des arbres
doit être suspendu quelques jours la
température est trop haut normalement
faut que ça gêne un petit peu le matin
puis jusqu'à 10 Celsius là c'est le
temps parfait pour couper mais pour
l'instant pas de crainte selon lui les
arbres seront quand même prêts à temps
pour descendre de telles températures en
automne avait été enregistré pour la
dernière fois en 1938 environnement
Canada prévoit qu'elle redescendront
graduellement dès la semaine prochaine
ici Charlotte Dumoulin Radio-Canada
Montréal